Після 24 червня багато критиків Кремля сподівалися на те,
що заколот Пригожина продемонструє вразливість путінського режиму.
Але наразі Путін не має наміру добровільно відмовлятися від влади,
про що свідчить підготовка до виборів.
Тому силовий шлях видається багатьом експертам
одним із найімовірніших сценаріїв зміни влади в Росії.
Власне, палацовий чи військовий переворот
- це єдиний наявний механізм для такої швидкої зміни режиму.
А альтернатив - дві. Це повільне гниття режиму до фізичного відходу Володимира Путіна,
або обвалення фронту і подальший розпад Росії на частини,
що воюють одна з одною.
Тому палацовий чи військовий переворот - це найкраще, що може на нас чекати.
Однак не виключено, що після невдалого заколоту в Кремлі
зробили відповідні висновки, після яких вертикаль влади тільки зміцнилася,
а у потенційних учасників заколоту поменшало шансів на успіх.
Із системою, як із людиною, працює той самий принцип
- все, що нас не вбиває, робить нас сильнішими.
А вбити систему ніхто навіть не намагався.
Йшлося про перерозподіл ролей.
І я думаю, що немає ані тих, хто міг би оскаржити лідерство Путіна.
Ані лідерів чи якихось організованих озброєних груп,
які могли б здійснити переворот чи заколот.
До того ж приклад Пригожина та його найближчого оточення,
які загинули в авіакатастрофі рівно через два місяці після заколоту,
ймовірно, мав за задумом Путіна продемонструвати новим можливим змовникам,
що з ними буде у разі нової спроби перевороту.
Це демонстративна акція. Зрештою, Пригожина можна було б тихенько отруїти
й він помер би від інфаркту, як багато попередніх супротивників Путіна
або його генерали.
Президенту Путіну потрібно було показати приклад.
Не може Євген Пригожин вчинити заколот, створити небезпечний прецедент і вижити.
Це дало б іншим людям ідеї.
Тепер ті інші люди, які спостерігали за тим, що сталося,
побачили дуже театральний, ефектний спосіб поводження з Пригожиним.
Вони зроблять висновки і відкоригують свій власний розрахунок ризику відповідно до цього.
Загроза існує і для тих, хто разом з Пригожиним брав участь у заколоті.
Логіка підказує, що будуть подальші дії.
Тому що зараз усі командири ПВК "Вагнер" знають, що Путін не прощає і не дотримується умов угоди.
Тому вони самі знаходяться під загрозою.
І є два способи уникнути такої загрози.
Один - втекти. Другий - повстати проти Путіна і боротися за своє життя.
Путін ніколи не прощає своїх ворогів.
Тому навіть вступ до російської армії не гарантує, що вони виживуть.
На думку експертів, режим за підсумками невдалого заколоту
може робити ставку на менш ефективних, але більш контрольованих людей.
Якщо Кремль продовжуватиме ставити на війну на виснаження,
на збереження статус-кво, то йому цілком достатньо мати Шойгу та Герасимова
як нехай не ефективних, але абсолютно лояльних керівників.
І він не експериментуватиме з людьми типу Пригожина,
які можуть бути більш ефективними, але за це теж доводиться платити.
Брати на себе нові ризики у Кремлі,
як вважають експерти, навряд чи готові.
Але чи може ситуація на фронті стати загрозливою для режиму Путіна?
Хтось скаже, що були сподівання України та західних союзників на контрнаступ.
Ці надії ще не закінчено.
Але мені так здається, що час уже закінчується.
А збройні сили Росії лише зміцнюються.
Тому мені важко уявити, що може бути корінним переломом на користь України,
який вплине на події в Росії.
Окрім перевороту та військової поразки, на думку експертів,
існує ймовірність падіння режиму в разі наростання внутрішніх конфліктів у Росії.
Припустімо, що розпочнеться відпад регіонів від центру та підуть відцентрові тенденції,
які зараз і так сильні.
Адже у нас є регіони, які в самостійному існуванні жили б значно краще,
безпечніше, багатше і так далі, ніж всередині Російської Федерації.
А того, що скріплює Російську Федерацію, стає з кожним днем дедалі менше.